recently Bungie invited us to a digital
preview event for lightfall the latest
Destiny expansion that's almost upon us
we got a chance to see a live demo of an
early story campaign mission a tour of
the new destination neomuna and a look
at some of the much requested features
like the mod manager menu Loadout
Creator and guardian ranks system and in
this video we're going to talk about the
interesting and important details we
took away I would also like to note the
footage that you are seeing is b-roll
provided by Bungie it is not the same as
the demo we saw so apologies if what I'm
talking about and what you're seeing
don't match up that's just how it goes
let's start with lightfall's newest
destination the neon soaked city of
neomuna we've never had a urban city
environment before that you can freely
roam around and explore the closest
being the first encounter in the scourge
of the past raid typically everything in
the universe of Destiny is abandoned or
destroyed getting to see a living
breathing city that has just come under
Fire is a new feeling for Destiny and
raises the stakes and yeah the look does
rule Bungie is really leaning into the
80s future city aesthetic complete with
holographic palm trees they even
mentioned that one of the Lost sectors
is an arcade which is just perfect
Bungie told us to expect neomuna to be
comparable in size to Europa and
sabathune's Throne World following these
same three bubble Loop these
destinations have I'm not necessarily
gonna go through and describe every
little bit of neemuna we saw you'll get
experience it for yourself on the 28th
also it's a destiny destination Bungie's
not really rocking the boat here at
least based on what I saw but I do want
to highlight a few little details I
liked the first is the neomuna Civil
news this is a radio report that comes
on over your comms and gives you small
little news reports about the city while
you explore I found this to be a neat
little bit of World building you get
while running around to your next
objective the second is a small but
meaningful addition to neomuna's Landing
Zone a place called strider's gate the
cloud starter Nimbus hangs out there as
the destination vendor but more
importantly there is wait for it a vault
in post box thank God I cannot express
how excited I am to have such a small
quality of life Edition especially
because as I'll touch on later having
access to your vault in more locations
might be more necessary now in the
campaign mission we got our first look
at fighting the shadow Legion a new
version of the cabal and the main force
will be fighting in the expansion from
what we saw this is still mainly the
same cabal enemy types we've been
fighting for years now so don't expect
any radical gameplay changes here
however some of them did have strand
Shield
enemy Shield type has always played a
key role in Destiny's combat Rhythm but
because stasis Shields never really
became a thing I originally wasn't
expecting strand to get them either it
feels like Bungie really wants strand to
feel like a major part of the combat
meta in all aspects in a way that stasis
kinda didn't get back when it first
launched and I'll be curious if we start
seeing strand Shields and content
outside of lightfall specific content
compared to stasis back and Beyond light
one of the more exciting differences is
how quickly Bungie lets you play with
the New Strand subclass in the mission
the guardian comes across this strand
pillar and when activated it gives
temporary access to the full strand
subclass to experience for a combat
encounter a huge complaint back in
Beyond light was that stasis itself was
blocked away for most of the campaign
and you only got to mess around with it
in small bits and pieces this is meant
to address that issue but because it's
just temporary you still get the
experience of unlocking and growing
strand over time Bungie also so said the
unlock process won't be as arduous as it
was with stasis as for strand itself it
looks awesome we gotta see a hunter in
action which is great for me because I'm
a Hunter man their new super silk strike
has them swinging around a rope dart
throwing it either strain enemies or
swinging it in a 360 degree motion the
effective strand itself is really really
cool looking the cabal look like their
physical form is unraveling until
nothing is left whenever they are hit
the hunter can also use the new grapple
feature more often while the super is
active and seeing the hunter zip around
the battlefield really makes it sink in
how strand has the potential to
completely change the feeling of combat
with this newfound Mobility neomuna
itself is designed to take advantage of
this all the combat areas we saw were
wide open city streets and rooftops
perfect for swinging around anywhere you
want without much issue of course this
doesn't mean you'll be able to Grapple
all the time as it does take up a
grenade slot which runs on cooldown
however neomuna is full of floating
strand grapple points you can use to
swing around and using these refunds to
Grenade energy in short you're going to
be spending a lot more time in the air
while exploring and fighting on neomuna
Bungie has stated they want combat bills
to become a large part of Destiny which
might be why some of the biggest Buzz
around lightfall is in its new location
or subclass but its system changes a
much requested feature from players me I
am players is the loadout system as
Destiny has grown further and further
into build crafting and leaning more
heavily on its RPG systems the lack of
an in-game Loadout system to save builds
created for certain content types or
subclasses has grown into a problem for
years we've been forced to rely on
third-party Solutions like Destiny item
manager Bungie has previously talked
about in detailed how the loadout system
will work but getting to see in action
has clarified a few important details
the most important being that yes
loadouts will pull from your Vault there
is also no limit to when and where you
can use a Loadout with the exception of
high-end content that uses the Lost
Loadout modifier such as Grandmaster
nightfalls as long as you have the space
in your inventory you're good to go
however the loadout system won't put
stuff back into your Vault meaning you
still have to rely on physically
returning to a vault location or using
Destiny item manager I asked Bungie if
there were concerns about situations
where players are regularly switching
loadouts and quickly filling up
inventory space for now this is the way
it is but they said they will listen to
community feedback if it becomes a major
pain point for players we also got a
look at the new mod manager menu which
sounds like it will make the actual
creation of your loadouts a lot easier
currently when creating a build it can
be a pain just to see what your guardian
has with numerous clicking in and out of
sub menus this is what the mod manager
menu is supposed to fix now on a single
screen you can see what perkster weapons
have and what mods are equipped on Armor
this is designed to make it easy to
screenshot and share your build with
other players in the same way people
share their transmog and Shader setup
the final component we got to look at
was Guardian ranks although I'm still
left with questions about it replacing
the triumphs menu is a new menu tab
called The Journey this new menu still
has all your titles and triumphs but now
includes your guardian rank Guardian
ranks are meant to create a better path
for new players while The Game's new
light introduction is a decent way to
get players familiar with the very
basics of gameplay once you get into the
tower you are overloaded with dozens of
vendors campaign missions ritual
activities and seasonal content it is an
overwhelming and off-putting experience
now Guardian ranks gives those players
guidance by giving them a path they can
follow that says here start with this
how well this will actually work remains
to be seen but I do appreciate Bungie
wanting to make the game simpler to
understand for veteran players Guardian
ranks are a new way to show off how good
at the game you
Your Guardian rank will Now display
above you and on your emblem card for
everyone to see I much prefer this over
showing a player's seasonal pass rank
which was less of a wow that player is
really skilled and has done a lot and
more look how much time this person has
spent grinding Bungie said that ranks do
change each season to account for new
content that means your rank does reset
to some degree but they've told us that
it's fairly easy to get back up to the
rank you previously had plus old ranks
are still saved for posterity the big
question is how does this all feel in
action many of the Guardian rank
objectives we saw tend to overlap with
what you already are doing for seals so
it seems like they are meant to work in
tandem with many of the achievement
chases already in the game rather than
being a whole new Grind to pursue it's
always difficult to tell how these new
abilities and systems will work out over
a short 45 minute demo and it's really
going to take a good week or two of
playing them ourselves to get a feel for
everything but that's said I'm really
excited for how committed Bungie is to
updating the game with some pretty major
changes this late into the game's life
this is the penultimate chapter in
Destiny's light and darkness Saga and
they could have easily chosen to just
focus on that and keep the game the same
but clearly Bungie has plans for a
destiny beyond the war between the
traveler and the witness and wants to
keep evolving the experience for players
lightfall might be the beginning of the
end for this storyline but it's also
starting to feel like a new era for
Destiny as a video game we'll find out
if this holds true when we get our hands
on lightfall on the 28th